et remarquez à chaque fois qu'une
élection se déroule on se plaint de
l'abstention on commande pendant une
semaine pendant deux semaines et puis
après on oublie jusqu'à l'élection
suivante on a décidé de faire exactement
l'inversé est d'apporter des réponses
parce que bien sûr si les gens vont pas
voter si vous n'allez pas voter c'est
parce que vous avez le sentiment de plus
avoir confiance dans la politique dans
l'efficacité de l'action publique
peut-être que les premiers responsables
sont les politiques et que globalement
il ya quelque chose de notre démocratie
qui nous met en malaise
alors bien sûr faut apporter des
réponses soient apportées des réponses
sur le fond sur le projet faut que les
politiques soient à l'écouté en même
temps et cette vision qui nous disent ce
que nous allons devenir ensemble comment
on peut recréer une espérance collective
dans cette société toujours trop
individualiste mais il ya aussi des
manières des méthodes pour servir ses
projets en proposant le vote par
correspondance
parce qu'aujourd'hui on peut faire
beaucoup de choses à distance mais
malheureusement pas voter en faisant
bouger sur la parité parce que dans les
communes de moins de 1000 habitants
aujourd'hui la parité n'est pas encore à
l'oeuvre il n'y a pas de raison de
considérer que les femmes ne pourraient
pas s'engager parce qu'elles vivent dans
des petites villes ou dans des villages
en faisant bouger sur la représentation
proportionnelle pour qu'on soit sûr
quand on va voter que le bulletin de
vote sera utile et permettra de nous
représenter
savoir mieux organiser les institutions
sur le terrain parce qu'on comprend plus
rien de ce qui se passe entre les
régions les départements les
intercommunalités les communes on a
besoin de savoir qui fait quoi qui est
responsable de quoi parce que la
politique c'est d'abord une
responsabilité une capacité à rendre
compte et puis bien sûr la participation
citoyenne parce que la démocratie elle
fonctionne sur deux jambes une
démocratie représentative pour vous
représenter mais une démocratie
participative
parce qu'on peut pas considérer quand on
est élu qu'on a obtenu un chèque en
blanc pour cinq ans ou pour six ans à
partir de là parce que la politique doit
se remettre en cause sur ce qu'elle fait
sur son efficacité
l'efficacité de l'action publique c'est
ça qui est attendu d'abord il faut aussi
qu'elles se donnent des méthodes au
service de ses projets pour moderniser
la démocratie et pour que nos
concitoyennes nos concitoyens et de
nouveau le le goût de l'espérance et le
goût de l'avenir